y regreso con ustedes pero esta vez para
hablar de economía con mi compañera
daniela hablando na buenas noches
daniela para usted hola buenas noches
angela vamos a empezar hablando de chile
que comienza a tomar forma otra reforma
de pensiones sí señora un proyecto de
ley aprobado en la cámara de diputados y
que ahora pasa al senado pretende que
los ciudadanos puedan retirar otro 10%
de lo que tienen en su fondo de
pensiones si pasa todos los trámites
incluida la aprobación del presidente
sebastián piñera podrán retirar un
mínimo de un millón de pesos chilenos y
un máximo de 43 millones de pesos o 5
mil 700 dólares en 30 días hábiles el
tema ha sido muy polémico angela el
gobierno dice que quienes se están
retirando los recursos se quedarán sin
nada para la vejez lo cierto es que en
julio se aprobó un primer retiro y en
apenas tres meses el 94% de los 11
millones de afiliados al sistema ya
había retirado 16 mil millones de
dólares en total
daniela una emisión del fondo monetario
internacional llegó hoy a argentina
háblenos de eso bueno
dar dos semanas en este país para
iniciar formalmente una renegociación de
deuda con el gobierno de ale de alberto
fernández hoy argentina tiene una deuda
de 324 mil millones de dólares más del
95 por ciento de su producto interno
bruto casi una quinta parte se los debe
a las multilaterales entre ellas el
fondo monetario internacional en 2018 el
gobierno de mauricio macri obtuvo un
cupo de 57 mil millones de dólares pero
se alcanzaron a desembolsar 44 mil
millones esa es la deuda justamente para
la que se buscan mejores condiciones y
aunque la situación económica no está
nada fácil este año el país ya logró una
refinanciación así que por qué no lograr
otra vamos a seguir hablando de américa
latina' empeora el panorama del mercado
laboral y de la seguridad alimentaria en
la región
bueno anjé las dos noticias por un lado
la cepal y la organización mundial del
trabajo actualizaron su informe sobre
perspectivas laborales en la región
estiman que recuperar los 47 millones de
empleos perdidos en la pandemia se
tomará por lo menos una
una de las consecuencias de la crisis es
lo que naciones unidas define como
inseguridad alimentaria aguda que
básicamente es una etapa previa al
hambre antes de la pandemia eran unos 4
millones de personas en esta situación y
ahora son 16 millones y esto solamente
en américa latina y sin contar venezuela
escuchemos el programa mundial de
alimentos que el número de personas con
inseguridad alimentaria aguda en 70
están podría aumentar en un 80% desde
149 millones antes de que el cob y 19
llegará a aproximadamente 270 millones
para fines de este año 2020 33 y daniela
la comisión europea de formuló cargos
contra el gigante de amazona bueno este
bloque de países cree que el gigante
estadounidense usa su tamaño y su poder
para obtener ventajas frente a sus
pequeños competidores de ventas en línea
amazon vende sus productos pero a su vez
les permite a terceros vender los suyos
a través de su plataforma y según la
comisión europea la empresa recopila
datos de estos clientes y después los
usa ilegalmente para ver qué es popular
y que no es popular entre los
consumidores escuchemos
nuestra preocupación no recae sobre el
conocimiento de amazon juicios sobre los
datos comerciales confidenciales de un
vendedor en particular
sino sobre los datos acumulados de más
de 800 mil vendedores activos en la
unión europea' que cubren más de mil
millones de productos en otras palabras
este es un caso de macro datos
dictation pues amazon se defendió y dice
que representa menos del 1 por ciento
del comercio minorista mundial angela y
por favor vamos con los indicadores de
la jornada
bueno las bolsas del mundo prolongaron
su racha alcista por las esperanzas de
que pronto habrá una vacuna contra el
kobe de 19 con excepción en the wall
street que cerró mixto en europa hubo
notables alzas por segundo día
consecutivo con madrid y londres a la
cabeza y en américa latina la bolsa de
lima se desplomó por la crisis política
y en argentina subió en medio de la
visita del fondo monetario para el
cierre de daniela le voy a pedir por
favor la cifra del día son 38 mil
millones de dólares que vendió en 2019
el día del soltero angela escuché bien
el festival anual de ventas en línea más
grande del mundo organizado por alí babá
este festival es incluso más grande que
el cyber monday en eeuu y se lleva a
cabo hoy en china con expectativas de
subir esas ventas gracias daniela y ya
volvemos en france 24
[Música]